want to reach a fair and reasonable
settlement with Junior doctors we
recognize the hugely important role that
they play Within the NHS that's why we
stand ready to have meaningful and
constructive talks with them as we have
had with other health unions as we have
in terms of responding at the budget to
concerns from doctors regarding their
pensions so we are ready to have
discussions with them but clearly a
demand for 35 over 20 000 pounds for
some Junior doctors is not fair or
reasonable and that is why we've not
been able to make progress so far but we
want to engage constructively we
recognize Junior doctors have been under
significant pressure particularly from
the pandemic and we want to work with
them to find a fair and reasonable
settlement